c'est non
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
on va voir en bavarois
en voulant allumer un feu de cheminée
avec des paperasse inutile je suis tombé
hier par hasard sur une page du tome 2
de la critique de la raison dialectique
de jean paul sartre écoutez plutôt
il faut revenir à cette première vérité
du marxisme ce sont les hommes qui font
l'histoire et comme c'est l'histoire qui
lie produit en tant qu ils la font nous
comprenons dans l'évidence que la
substance de l'acte humain si elle
existait serait au contraire le non
humain ou à la rigueur le pré humains en
tant qu'il est justement la matérialité
discrète de chacun
cet extrait du chapitre intitulé
l'intelligibilité de l'histoire
évidemment si vous n'arrêtez pas
tripoter votre belle soeur en conduisant
pendant que je cause dans le poste vous
n'êtes pas prêt de comprendre les
vérités premières du marxisme alors on
se calme pouf pouf je répète ne m'écoute
et bien il faut revenir à cette première
vérité du marxisme ce sont les hommes
qui font l'histoire et comme si
l'histoire qui les produit en tant qu
ils la font nous comprenons dans
l'évidence que la substance de l'acte
humain si elle existait serait au
contraire le non humain ou à la rigueur
le prix humain en tant qu'il est
justement la matérialité discrète de
chacun
non mais je sais ce que ça y est d y ait
des belles soeurs qui font exprès de
mettre leur ceinture de sécurité parce
que ça fait ressortir les nichons alors
évidemment on est dispersée
cela dit vous n'avez pas tout à fait
tort c'est pas très clair
l'intelligibilité de l'histoire il doit
s'être glissé une de coki dans ce texte
il suffit peut-être de changer un mot ou
deux pour que l'intelligibilité de
vienne intelligible exemple il faut
revenir à cette première vérité du
marxisme ce sont les chiens qui font
whaou et comme si le wawa qui les
produit en tant qu ils le font nous
comprenons dans l'évidence que la
substance de l'acte canin si elle
existait certes au contraire le nom wawa
ou à la rigueur le prévoit en tant qu'il
est justement la matérialité discrète de
chacun
c'est à dire une vérité qu'on peut à la
rigueur et tendre à l'informatique
simplement en passant de des chiens opus
la cie il faut revenir à cette première
vérité du marxisme ce sont les puces qui
font les ordinateurs et comme c'est
l'ordinateur qui les produit en tant qu
elles le font nous comprenons dans
l'évidence que la substance de
l'ordinateur si elle existait serait au
contraire le nom puce ou à la rigueur le
prépuce en tant qu'il est justement la
matérialité discrète de chacun
il faut bien voir que quand sartre
écrivait ce genre de conneries à la fin
des années 50 il ne se prenait pas
encore au sérieux il est vrai qu'ils
n'avaient pas encore été nommé pape db à
de la rive gauche il écrivait surtout
pour du pognon ou pour faire rigoler
gens qu
il se contentait de cachetonner dans des
feuilles de chou anti-fasciste primaire
avec une mauvaise foi c'est pas honnête
c'est vrai il faut revenir sur cette
vérité première du fascisme en réalité
ce sont les étrangers qui foutent le
bordel
et comme si le bordel qu'il est produit
en tant qu il le foot nous comprenons
dans l'évidence que la substance de
lentilles bordel si elle existait serait
au contraire le nom [ __ ] ou à la
rigueur le pré [ __ ] en tant qu'île
et la matérialité discrète de chacun
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour capter n'empêche qu'ils
font rien qu'à bugis renom campagne
[Musique]
fait que mon nom